So here was our problem. Data.largest returns a measurable. That's all it can
return, because the data class knows nothing about countries. We need a
country, and the answer is simply to cast. The cast is legitimate, the largest
country had to be one of the countries that was put in, and its proof safe to
convert back from a measurable to the country. let's think once more what
advantage we get from the measurable interface. When you look at the BlueJ,
display of classes and the interfaces, you can clearly see that country and car
both implement the measurable interface. You can see that the data class uses
the measurable interface, that's the dotted line here. And what's important is
that the data class knows absolutely nothing about country's cars or any other
classes. It's decoupled from those classes, and that's what makes it, so
generic. Now, Sarah will introduce you to an interface that's much more
commonly used, a comparable interface.